hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2019 american drama movie called root of
the problem
the movie begins with a middle-aged man
named paul campbell who works as a
realtor for rush real estate
he always inspects and prepares the
house before he sells it but not always
in a proper way
as a result his customers are always
satisfied with his service
after selling the house he returns to
the office and invites his best friend
and co-worker jack to come over to a
barbecue party at his house
the evening has come and everyone
gathers at paul's place
paul's wife grace seems to be jealous of
michelle jack's wife as jack's always
buying nice things for her
turns out that paul is a very stingy
person
his wife isn't even allowed to donate to
the children foundation that michelle
runs thus she only has the chance to do
it when he is not around
a few moments later grace receives a
call from the hospital and is informed
that his uncle john has just passed away
uncle john and grace have been close for
a long time that's why grace is
devastated when she hears the news
afterward the couple meets the lawyer to
discuss the inheritance that uncle john
left
pastor riley who is uncle john's best
friend also presents at the meeting room
paul is shocked when he learns that they
will receive a plan instead of money to
make things worse the lawyer also states
that paul has to sell the uncle's house
and all the money will be donated to a
kid's camp the couple are highly
disappointed with the result and paul
even wants to immediately throw the
plant away
upon arriving home paul gets angry
because the inheritance was not as
expected and he knows that uncle john
was rich while grace believes that the
plant must be important to the uncle at
the end he decides to leave the plant
outside the house
apart from being ungenerous paul is also
an arrogant person as he always mocks
jack every time he makes a sale claiming
he is better than him
in the evening when grace asks him about
uncle john's house paul looks reluctant
to sell it because he won't receive any
money at all from the sale as it will be
donated in the morning paul rebukes his
son landon for sharing his food with his
friend
his daughter carrie is also fed up with
her father's behavior after buying some
drinks from a coffee shop paul and jack
encounter an unemployed guy asking for
money as expected jack donates several
cents to him while paul isn't willing to
give a single penny
paul who is envious of a big project
jack is working on voluntarily offers
himself to help him and wants half of
the commission after the sales
because they are best friends jack
reluctantly agrees to the offer after
work paul tidies up the shed and moves
the plant there he then waters the
mysterious plant and accidentally
discovers that the plant can generate
money he harvests several hundred
dollars from it but suddenly his
children and wife approach him
he doesn't tell them about the plant's
magic and acts like nothing has happened
because he promised to help jack paul
goes to an old factory that jack's going
to sell where jack has been raking for a
while
they examine the place and paul
concludes that the factory needs some
cleaning and repairing they climb up to
the second floor where they find a hole
in the railing which can be dangerous
however they ignore the problem and
cover the hole with a sheet
that night paul diligently waters the
plant that keeps growing money for him
he enters the house and is panicked when
grace claims that she watered the plant
earlier but she did not find anything
strange which relieves him
the following day pastor riley pays a
visit and asks for a donation for the
church fundraiser
the entire house is confused with paul
who all of a sudden becomes generous and
donates an enormous amount of money to
pastor riley
paul even changes his appearance as an
outfit
thanks to the plant paul keeps
harvesting money from it and has become
rich
however he still doesn't want to share
the secret to the family for the first
time paul gives a lot of pocket money to
his children
carrie and landon question their dad's
behavior and hope that he keeps behaving
like that
paul effortlessly wastes his money for
not urgent stuff such as a 5 000
lawnmower
grace gets angry because she thinks it's
unnecessary to buy the vehicle and
become suspicious as they never had that
much money
he admits that he gets the money from
the factory sales commission
after arguing paul sneaks into the shed
and harvests more and more money
at this point he has received 100 000
from the plant
offended by jack who says that his car
doesn't fit his image paul immediately
buys a brand new 65 grand sports car in
cash
not long after the car salesman is
confronted by a tax officer named miller
due to the car purchase and cash and she
wants to conduct a deeper investigation
on paul
he shows off the car to jack and tells
him that he got the money from uncle
john
paul drives his new sports car home but
it seems like grace is not happy with it
after dinner she asks him how much the
car costs and realizes that her husband
is hiding something from her
paul ended up having to sleep on the
couch the next day pastor riley comes to
paul and asks for a donation again but
this time he refuses to donate
riley also learns that paul hasn't sold
uncle john's house
while paul is away detective miller
comes to his house and questions grace
about paul's spending an income
grace defends her husband saying that he
is the top realtor
miller then leaves as she prefers to
talk directly to paul
a few moments later the detective is
informed that paul's income dropped off
the last couple years making it
unrealistic to buy a sports car money in
cash
she also secretly observes paul's
activities from a distance
soon after paul is depressed when he
figures out that the plan has stopped
growing money and grace keeps
questioning about where the cash came
from
she is freaking out because she is
afraid her husband is doing something
illegal realizing he has done something
terrible paul pays a visit to pastor
riley and gives some money for the
church fundraiser
riley lectures him about the law of
attraction and advises paul to help
others more often
paul agrees with him and decides to
donate more money
just after paul leaves detective miller
confronts riley and finds ten thousand
dollars on the desk
paul is frustrated and suddenly starts
reading the bible since the plant has
not generated any money recently
he begins to regret his action and
realizes that he is ruining his own life
the next morning paul is supposed to
accompany his son to his hockey game but
he left early which makes landon upset
paul goes to the coffee shop as usual in
this time he gives some money to the
unemployed man who feels weird seeing
this salesman giving free money without
any reason
meanwhile miller keeps monitoring paul's
every move
after he leaves the detective arrests
the man after suspecting them of doing a
drug deal
afterward paul meets jack at the factory
and asks for his help to cover for him
he also ignores several calls from his
wife
unbeknownst to him grace and carrie head
over to the factory where carrie
accidentally falls off and breaks her
arm because she didn't know there's a
big hole on the railing
carrie is immediately brought to the
hospital by jack and grace in the
hospital jack knows that it was his
fault for not fixing the railing
he also gets angry at paul and states
that he should never listen to paul
he then walks away
grace receives a call from jack's wife
who reveals that she has never seen jack
so angry
after that paul regrets his decision and
apologizes to his wife
in the morning kerry is discharged from
the hospital and jack is very happy with
the news
however landon is disappointed with his
dad
paul admits his mistake in hopes that
landon will give him a second chance
the son eventually forgives him
shortly after detective miller and an
officer come and arrest paul because she
believes he is involved in illegal
activity
in the jail he also meets pastor riley
and the unemployed man who were also
taken into custody for receiving money
from paul
turns out that pastor reilly knows about
the plan all along and reveals that he
was the man who gave uncle john that
plant he adds that uncle john was once
like paul but he was unhappy
because of that uncle john decided to
spend most of his money for charitable
causes which helped him to find his real
destiny
paul then realizes that he must change
into a better person in order for the
plant to grow money again
paul also learns the shocking fact that
the kids camp that uncle john always
donated to was run by grace's parents
before they passed away thanks to jack's
kindness for explaining the commission
from the factory sales to miller all of
them are then set free
since then paul decides to get involved
in the kids camp and donate his brand
sports car as a grand prize and a raffle
everyone especially jack and grace is
proud of him now
at the end of the movie the family
finally has the opportunity to go on a
long vacation together and pastor riley
will take care of the plant from now on
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching